I just got out of sony's press
conference and they announced a lot of
different things ain't now so the new
vaio computers they now is who line up
bra vias and they even announced that a
new camera is called the blogging it is
my pleasure to introduce blogging yes
you heard me right blogging it's not
just for those involved with social
networking but with several of the same
features and shooting options found in
more expensive and borders for the one
thing they spent a lot of time on was
their 3d technology our goal is to have
a common undisputed global leader in 3d
so they announced that a new line of
bravia television sets are going to be
3d capable but you're not going to be
forced to buy it right away the glasses
and the transmitters are gonna be sold
separately so if you don't want 3d you
don't have to have it another part is
Sony's 3d strategy is the PlayStation 3
that's going to be upgradeable for 3d
technology we'd be able to play 3d games
on it and you'll also be able to watch
3d blu-ray movies another announcement
they made was that they were going to
partner with ESPN and discovery channel
es bands going to show the people world
cup sometime in 2010 in 3d and
discoveries going to show original
programming awesome 3d hopefully shark
reef I can't wait to have a great white
swimming at me so Sony is investing a
lot of time money and resources into 3d
we're a little skeptical we're not sure
if 3d is going to fly because it's it's
it's expensive first of all so you have
to buy the glasses and the TV set and
the transmitter and also we're not sure
if everybody going to sit in their
living room and put on the glasses and
high-five each other while they're
watching shark week or the FIFA World
Cup
you